so to become an Avengers other love
trials can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
what's up guys
none of this would have happened if you
a jerk listen to me go back because
we're waiting ago a guy is still out
there I just got to do this on my own
spider-man homecoming
[Music]
what's up guys so to become an Avenger
other like trials or an Olivia do me a
favor
can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man just stay close
to the ground
you're the spider-man from YouTube can
you summon anomaly exploiters oh yeah no
no I have to stop she'll come into the
suit on that the rich and the powerful
like start they don't care about the
world's changing voice and we changed to
weapons a crazy dangerous listen traitor
forget the flying monster guy there are
people who handle this way
Yuri the weapons Barry was a 230 you
missed it
[Music]
what if somebody had died I was just
trying to be like you I want you to be
better I'm gonna need the check back
well nothing without this suit if you're
nothing without this suit then you
shouldn't have it I screwed up you need
to stop carrying the weight of the world
on your shoulders I want you to
understand he'll do anything to get my
family
I know you know what I'm talking about
don't mess with me
I'll kill you and everybody you look
a guy who's still out there I just got
to do this on my own
just don't do anything stupid
all right yeah
you